expenses
Michael is that a wig
no
that's I wear it like that sometimes is
that a wig
this is from Hooters yeah it's a
business lunch did Toby approve this no
he did not I don't need his permission
you just got your corporate credit card
back you really want me to take it away
again it's ridiculous they took my card
away because I spent 80 bucks at a magic
shop what they don't understand is that
I bought the stuff to impress potential
clients so business related right I put
a cigarette through a freaking quarter
and you know what Toby they almost
bought from us I'm not processing it
can you confirm that the straps are
tight
yes
but this and now the chains
a lot of people think that magic Camp is
just for kids and that's why so many
other people in my class were kids
self-fulfilling prophecy it's um really
for anybody with a dream and a belief in
magic
and a little extra time after school
magic magic
and now
Michael the magic will attempt to escape
from extreme bondage
can he do it I don't see how he can I
know how
dislocate his shoulder and slip his arm
out
no everyone now count down with me three
sorry quick thing so is it true that if
you can't get out you don't want anyone
to help you I will get out oh yes I will
so we shouldn't help you no matter how
much you might beg and please no all
right just this is getting hot so let's
just do this okay ready three
two one go
[Applause]
is everything okay Michael
yes
I cannot tell you how I plan to escape
other than by using magic that is the
Magician's Code
separately on an unrelated note if you
happen to find a small
brass key
go go go go
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no
nobody
[Music]
are you crazy
foreign
[Music]
Toby how do we do
well that that was better
[Applause]
I need somebody to pick a card
one of the new people please Tony I'll
do it all right good
thank you do not look at your car
now I've always said
that to be a great salesman is to have
the ability to connect with people right
here so to be a great salesman is to be
a king of hearts
turn over your car
King of Hearts very good Michael really
good
so I think in order for us all to work
together well we must come together as a
family
and then we can all be a
King
of
hearts
that was fantastic no no it's better
than fantastic it's super perfect